let's talk about handling detractors or
haters you have experienced some
backlash and it seems rather unfair can
you can you talk about this I mean we've
heard about celebrities out there who
don't read the Yahoo comments and I'm
always curious who these people on Yahoo
so write all this but do you even bother
look look I look at it like this I I
review people's work for a living so if
somebody wants to review my work it's
all good
say whatever you want is just about my
work and it's professional and that's
fine but when he gets into a space of
criticizing your family or just taking
personal shots of you then it kind of
falls on deaf ears I interviewed Woody
Allen last night I'm sitting down
Penelope Cruz today I'm doing fine you
know people I understand that you know
there'd be a line around the block for
any one of my jobs so I'm in a really
lucky position and I've been working
consistently for a long time now so I
understand that there are people out
there Levis attitude of why is he doing
this I can do this
and you know what the right like you can
do this they go for it knock yourself
out i surf I support so many
up-and-coming filmmakers up-and-coming
journalists you know people in the
business all walks of the business who
are trying to get into it I support a
lot of people as they try to make a name
for themselves and I encourage everyone
go for it I get on the plane and go fly
the Louisiana and do a set visit and fly
back and do it you know and go see do it
go for it I'm not stopping you so if
people want to consume themselves with
trying to stop me from doing what I love
doing then that that's on them they
there though I've confronted a lot of
the people who have said certain things
about me over the years and some are
rather I don't know how to articulate ly
say this but whatever we're just really
scared when you come up to them and you
say hey I saw you can writing a lot of
things about them Ben we've never met
but you seem to really be into what I'm
doing I've seen people run I've seen
people not shy oh no I didn't mean it by
that and some big important people like
people that you and I we both
watch their work and we know them I've
come up to them and said hey do you
really need to call me stupid when
you're on that radio show I didn't mean
that but everybody backs off then so if
you say something about me or write
something about my work it's totally
fine I could care less honestly because
I'm still working and doing what I love
but at least stand behind it at least at
least you know I don't know how else to
say it so it's interesting it's
interesting to me and it's funny to me
and it's been like it's been a funny
part of my career to have to deal with
that and I've kind of dealt with it by
not dealing with it like I'm this is
something I grew up in I'm very proud of
my work I work really hard you can ask
any actor I interview I'm always
professional I'm always on time
I've been doing this for a long time now
so it's funny to me of these people
they're I don't think they're you really
really still do it anymore but it was
more so when I was doing at the movies
that they were really consumed with
every single move I made and it just got
to a point where I was it had to be
tiresome for them on some level so I
don't know if they gave up or they quit
or whatever it was but I'm still here
working and I'm gonna continue to work
and I produced a movie that was at
Tribeca this year I'm very proud of that
I'm you know I'm traveling a lot to
movie sets and doing my thing like I
honestly couldn't be happier so it does
that make somebody else happy and they
do what they gotta do that's fine
well do you almost take it as a
compliment because it's definitely a
validation in your position knowing you
know people don't people don't hate down
too much people hate up a lot and I've
noticed that in all walks of life and so
if there are people out there consumed
with transcribing my movie reviews and
breaking down every sentence that I said
then I mean it's a validation of my
position of the business and and like I
said I criticize people's work for a
living as a film critic I have in the
past so someone wants to criticize my
work who might say no they can't
obviously they can but when they make it
personal and they take it farther than
it falls on deaf ears really
you